étranger
[Music]
poisson ours
polaire tout ce sur quoi nous mettons la main
est
[Music] l'
une des communautés les plus touchées par le
changement climatique dans tout le Canada si nous
ne faisons rien à ce sujet très rapidement,
nous pourrions nous heurter à une catastrophe et si
nous devons déménager d'ici nous
ne saurions pas je n'ai aucune idée d'où nous
allons aller
à
Vivian pommes de terre
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
étranger [
International
étranger
T est une falaise solide
ici et c'est le pergélisol
c'est tellement  euh évident quand vous venez de comprendre à
quoi ressemble le changement climatique et
c'est juste dans votre visage
Je viens de la Nouvelle-Écosse J'ai vécu là-bas
toute ma vie quand je pense à l'
érosion côtière Je pense à vous savez de fortes vagues
frappant la côte et  et provoquant l'
érosion du matériau avec cette puissance
des vagues qui se produit ici aussi,
mais ce qui se passe également, c'est que la
température de l'air devient de plus en plus chaude et de plus
en plus chaude, ce qui se passe lorsque vous
augmentez bien la température de l'air,
évidemment ce pergélisol va
dégeler alors  vous avez le dégel du pergélisol
sur la côte et vous avez l'impact
des vagues
étrangères L'
océan Arctique diminue et cela devient
de moins en moins chaque année et vous avez
des saisons d'eau libre plus longues que vous connaissez
dans une région où la glace était gelée
solidement au  banque pendant neuf mois par an
peut-être que maintenant vous savez même aussi peu
que sept mois et demi de
glace solide gelée alors maintenant nous avons plus d'eau et
plus de temps pour que les vagues frappent la côte
[Musique]
tout cela n'est pas consolidé euh vous savez du
matériel  qui peut être facilement emporté
et donc tout ce matériel à l'avant
ici, le sable qui a été évacué
du haut, il est tout simplement emporté par la
mer instantanément ou sur ces immenses
plages ici depuis les vagues
et puis vous  on se retrouve à nouveau avec un visage propre
et puis les choses
commencent à s'effondrer et puis le processus recommence
planète
tant que le pergélisol est gelé, il
contient tout ce carbone qui est un grand
potentiel pour les gaz à effet de serre à la
fin mais aussi longtemps  comme c'est gelé c'est bon c'est
là c'est sûr ça ne va
rien faire mais parce que ça tague et
c'est parce que ça va tellement vite tout
ce carbone va finir dans le système
va se dégrader ou la barge va se
dégrader et ça va être émis au fur et à mesure  un
gaz à effet de serre et renforçant ainsi
ce cycle de réchauffement
étranger
[Musique]
si vous arrêtez les vagues, alors vous arrêtez la
majorité de l'érosion, pensez bien à
Tuck Island comme une barrière naturelle à
ces vagues derrière c'est la
communauté que nous pensons en fonction de son
rythme actuel  d'érosion élévation du niveau de la mer dans les
projections d'augmentation de la température de l'air
nous pensons que l'île de tuck pourrait disparaître dans
les 18 à 25 prochaines années c'est
scientifiquement dans la vie de chacun je
regarde les données physiques je peux
vous dire que là où se trouve la communauté là où
le  L'hôpital est l'endroit où vous savez que, à l'
approche du cimetière, un certain nombre de
maisons seront perdues dans la mer au cours des
25 à 50 prochaines années.
que d'énormes portions de
la communauté seront sous l'eau pendant
les tempêtes je ne pense pas que les gens que
vous connaissez euh dans certains cas nous aurons même
le choix de rester car il
n'y aura pas de terre sur laquelle rester il disparaît
on nous dit que  euh 2040
que l'île tuck n'existera plus
si on ne fait rien ce qui est
dans 18 ans et quand on y pense
c'est un clin d'œil
[Musique]
explique [
Musique]
est [
[Musique]
étrangère
[Musique  ]
Je suis né et j'ai grandi dans ma communauté de
Tuck. J'ai continué à vivre ici. Mes enfants
vivent ici.
Tout le monde est lié à cette communauté
d'une manière ou d'une autre.
dans notre emplacement qui est très unique,
nous essayons de
rechercher un financement afin de pouvoir protéger
notre littoral pour nous donner plus de temps,
vous savez, pour déménager à l'avenir si
vous regardez ici, vous pouvez voir comment les
dalles de ciment commencent à se soulever
ils ont fait leur travail, vous savez, ces
30 40 dernières années, ce
sont
des mères [de musique], je veux que vous réunissiez tous vos
adolescents et que vous les rassembliez
autour de la radio. Je veux vous raconter une
petite histoire
qui était une fille ensemble
essence
si nous  a fait un pitch et est parti
c'est un énorme problème à cause d'une
raison culturelle sentimentale il y a
des gens dans la communauté qui ne veulent pas
simplement se lever et partir il y a
un attachement il y a l'
aspect culturel l'une des grandes choses dont
vous nous connaissez ne pas vouloir  faire quelque chose
comme ça, c'est que nous avons un cimetière juste
contre l'océan ici
que nous devons protéger aussi longtemps que nous le
pouvons,
il est super important qu'ils nous écoutent
ici
et les grandes fosses avec le
gouvernement fédéral en ce moment, c'est le changement climatique
il y a  pas de meilleur exemple de
changement climatique qu'en ce moment,
vous savez que mon urgence est différente de celle de
quelqu'un du sud
parce que je vis ici et je le vois
tous les jours, nous avons regardé nous avons regardé les
vagues à l'automne et le niveau de la mer
montant et l'action des vagues qui est
arriver à voir des maisons tomber dans l'
océan
et à peine obtenir de l'aide pour y faire
face, c'est ce qui me frustre à
l'étranger, il
y a tellement de choses à voir les océans arctiques là-bas,
vous savez si vous venez en été, c'est
le meilleur moment, c'est un endroit vraiment riche
je  'je ne vivrais jamais ailleurs
[Musique]
étranger
donc c'est la petite station météo a
un anémomètre de vent qui est la
direction du vent la vitesse du vent a une température de l'air
mais a aussi une caméra en
termes de communauté c'est un
site très important il est capable de  regardez la
glace de mer la glace de mer fond et aussi
quand la glace de mer a disparu l'impact
des vagues et de la côte c'est une zone
où ils viennent pour la
récolte de subsistance et pour qu'ils sachent
dans quoi ils s'embarquent si c'est du brouillard  ou
des vagues avant qu'ils ne fassent le Trek ici,
je pense que c'est
nous allons devoir
déplacer le
finalement comme si c'était inévitable c'est triste
mais comme vous ne pouvez pas vous devez
y aller je suppose que si vous êtes comme moi  et la
plupart des gens aiment qu'ils n'aiment pas qu'on leur
dise quoi faire
alors euh ouais je pense qu'il est important que
la communauté ait le choix et
euh ils arrivent à
euh aider à planifier ce qu'ils veulent voir dans
leur nouvelle communauté
bien serré
juste  il faut déplacer un fil et on y va ça
marche ça marche maintenant ouais
à la fin de la journée personne ne veut
partir
personne ne veut partir là où nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment difficile pour nous de dire oui nous
allons devoir
nous avons une histoire de pensionnats
et de tout ce genre de choses où les gens ont été
emmenés et n'avaient
plus le choix, il est important que
les dirigeants de la communauté éduquent notre communauté pour
dire que tout va bien et que nous devons le faire,
mais nos gens écouteront nos gens,
nous sommes le  les gens qui vont
vivre dans un nouvel endroit, ça pourrait être
bien si la communauté comme vous le savez
nous dit comme ce qu'ils veulent voir
leur nouvelle communauté ressembler
aux conversations étrangères du Nord-Ouest [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
d'accord,
c'est en fait la première maison dans laquelle nous
avons emménagé ici qui avait de
l'eau courante
qui était dans les années 60
étrangère
[Music]
Delta [
Music]
eh bien, vous pouvez voir où les
berges commencent à tomber,
whoa Kingfisher doit couper un nid  en dessous, il y
a
bien, nous allons bien, nous avons
survécu à un autre hiver, je veux dire si
quelque chose un peu d'excitation une fois par
an,
tout le monde a besoin d'un peu d'
excitation de temps en temps, donc
le Delta est
étranger
[Musique]
Usine étrangère alors ils '  Je ne descends
plus
Je me souviens que quelques fois je suis venu ici
et j'ai juste tiré depuis le bateau
Trapper et c'était sa zone et
aussi toute la question de la relocalisation est
comme non ce n'est pas pour nous,
vous pensez qu'il y a une chance qu'une
réaction comme celle-ci se produise à
Tuck c'est leur terrain de chasse c'est
leur zone ils se sont adaptés à cela
similaire à  comment nous nous sommes adaptés ici,
donc la relocalisation non seulement
je me perdrais si elle était
déplacée  pensez à
vous savez que nous ne nous soucions pas des baleines
et qu'il est
difficile d'obtenir des baleines maintenant, je veux dire
à l'époque, les 10 familles attendaient au moins la
saison des cailles à
l'étranger,
souvenez-vous que mon père était sorti
quand j'étais jeune avec un autre Hunter et
ils  Je tirerais quelques baleines
ici
et le travail commencerait, mais quand vous aurez
fini de rentrer chez vous et que vous serez de
nouveau prêt pour l'hiver, ce ne sont que des
souvenirs que
nous ne voyons plus.
est très important ici
mais ce n'est pas un
changement dans le sens où tout
était stable et maintenant tout est
changé
[Musique]
si vous vivez avec la
transformation perpétuelle, alors
ce qui se passe avec le changement climatique n'est
pas si radicalement différent
[Musique]
il y en a  des écrivains indigènes qui
disent que je suis le changement climatique pour les
peuples indigènes
ce n'est pas une apocalypse imminente après euh une
longue histoire de stabilité et de bonheur
mais l'apocalypse pour les peuples indigènes
s'est déjà produite
[Musique]
ils ne font pas face au changement climatique à
partir d'une position  de tout allait bien
et maintenant tout à coup il y a un problème mais
ils sont confrontés au changement climatique
d'une position dans laquelle nous vivons
ils disent que nos ancêtres post-apocalypse
la caméra
le
code solaire japonais
est
étranger
Le meilleur scénario de relocalisation je me sens
il est temps nous avons le temps maintenant et nous avons
le temps de dire aux gens que vous connaissez
euh à quoi ressemble la réinstallation
pour vous et à quoi ressemblerait un futur tuck
pour vous
vous parlez de choses comme ça vous devez
avoir un certain nombre de personnes  à bord
en ce moment, dans ma position, cela a
été une bataille pour que nous puissions
élaborer un plan stratégique pour l'avenir, mais
en même temps, nous devons être agressifs
et intelligents à ce sujet pour nous assurer qu'il
existe un endroit appelé tuck  à un
moment donné dans le futur
[Musique]
merci, s'il vous plaît,
gardez
le destin étranger
étranger
[Musique]
l'environnement change mais nous pouvons nous
adapter, nous serons toujours là vous
savez que nous sommes des gens résilients et euh le
changement n'est pas nouveau pour nous